Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Union oder Pauli, hä?
Wir sind
Ja, soziales wir leben unter in der Bahnhofsmission.
Ich äh wie das war falsch.
War falsch. Der Text war falsch. Wir schlafen unter Brücken. Leben.
Naja, Anfänger.
Nee, ich ich schlafe da halt nicht nur, ne. Ich lebe da richtig.
Pauli alles Anfänger.
Oh Mann, ey. Timmy, ich habe dir gesagt.
Wir gehen mal morgen zum Spiel, mal kieken, wie's ausgeht.
Er hat ja gesagt, riskiere hier nix.
Naja, doch ich riskiere immer alles. Ich gehe immer voll auf die Zwölf. Aber ich weiß jetzt keinen Spruch, weißt du? Ja, ich glaube.
Na ja, ich im Gegensatz zu dir bin ich ja regelmäßig an der alten Försterei und du musst halt also das äh warte mal, sieht das Ding immer,
und dann aber sagen sie und niemals vergessen und dann musst du schreien.
Okay, da arbeite ich dran. Ja. Wenn wir uns dann vielleicht dann doch erstmal äh den Themen, den netzpolitischen Themen äh der Woche zu oder vielleicht auch erstmal den Themen der letzten Woche oder wir haben noch ein bisschen Rückblick, oder?
Wir haben wir haben einen Rückweg und ich habe, ich wollte noch so kurz was äh äh noch eine kurze Nachmeldung sagen. Ähm,
Was zu dem, was wir am Ende besprochen haben
Äh und zwar war ja meine Kernthese, dass äh Politik inzwischen nur noch Verwaltung ist und ähm sich im Prinzip also den äh nicht mehr
also nicht mehr große vernünftige oder nicht mehr große wirkliche Änderungen vorgenommen werden. Das heißt, es wird eher so ein System,
Gesellschaftssystem verwaltet und nicht eins entwickelt.
Und das ist aber, das wurde dann von einigen Kommentatoren als äh politische Äußerung verstanden, dass aber eigentlich inzwischen so relativ unstrittig. Also es würde keiner mehr ernsthaft in Frage stellen, in den Politikwissenschaften, dass die Sachen so laufen,
Und dann fiel mir noch ein, dass ich die ganze Zeit ja so Sozialstaat als Beispiel genommen habe, aber woran man es viel besser alles sehen kann, dieses Phänomen, ist Finanzkrise,
weil da da sieht man genau, dass sich das keine ähm also es wurde nicht mehr in Frage gestellt.
Ähm das Verhalten, wie man sich in diese Situation gebracht hat, also dass eventuell grundsätzlich
das System in Anführungszeichen, dass das Wirtschaftssystem anfällig für solche Sachen ist und dass man da irgendwie ernsthaft meine nennenswerte Änderung dran vornehmen könnte.
Das heißt, die also selbst in der Situation, in der das gesamte äh Wirtschaftssystem global droht, vor die Wand zu rennen.
Gab's nicht ernsthaft ähm mal jemanden oder wurde der wurde dem Gedanken dieses Wirtschaftssystem mal grundsätzlich zu überdenken.
Aufmerksamkeit.
Keine Aufmerksamkeit. Das war so dieses klassische Einstein, ne? Probleme löst man nicht mit der selben Denkweise, mit der sie entstanden sind.
Und das kann man da halt genau beobachten. Fiel mir nur so als Beispiel an. Ähm dann fiel mir noch so äh,
das wäre so, dass ich eigentlich zwei Sachen, also dass ich zu den zu der Rolle des Politikers zwei Sachen gesagt habe, nämlich einmal, dass man so sich den Stand hassen, dass man sich so einen standhaften Politiker eigentlich wünschen würde, ja, der also sagt, äh
Ich stehe für das ein und ich gehe auch damit unter, wenn wenn die, wenn ich's nicht schaffe, äh damit zu überzeugen,
sein Fähnchen immer in den wind hängenden Politiker. Ähm das macht im Prinzip keinen Unterschied. Also dafür wird ja dann noch korrigiert. Ähm,
Also ich meine These ist ja immer, ich sage ja immer, mir ist völlig egal, welche welche politische Person das durchsetzt, was ich gerne möchte.
Ja, also da bin ich äh, da sind alle gleich. Ähm, wenn sie das machen, was ich möchte, dann äh heiße ich das gut,
Äh du hast halt den Vorteil bei so einem bei dem alten Modell des standhaften Politikers mit Überzeugung, dann ist der halt vorhersagbarer. Und heute sind die das ja nicht mehr. Das kann man aber als Vor-und als Nachteil werten. Ähm,
Aber das das Wichtigste ist eigentlich, dass die Politik ja nicht mehr also das, womit sich die Gesellschaft auseinandersetzt in der politischen Debatte, äh nicht,
Dadurch bestimmt wird, dass dass Dinge mit mit Plan,
diskutiert werden, sondern dadurch bestimmt wird, was diskutiert wird und wann es diskutiert wird. Also klassische äh Agenda Setting Teil, ja? Also du willst zu deinem,
Zu dem opportunen Moment ein Thema setzen. Und da gibt's dann zum Beispiel,
Erwägungen, dein Thema, eine Zeit lang nicht
an die an die Tagesordnung zu bringen, weil gerade das Wetter, das politische Großwetter eben äh nicht so ist, dass sie das äh dass wir das ähm so durch das Parlament und durch die Regierung bekommst, dass es dir gefällt.
Also wie zum Beispiel generell das Timing mit Wahlen.
Genau, so Wahlen ähm aber auch, es gibt halt günstige Zeitpunkte, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu fordern und ungünstige.
Jetzt ist gerade ein ungünstiger. Ja, aber das kannst du halt ganz einfach dadurch umgehen, dass du dass du wartest.
Na ja, solche Sachen wollte ich mal. Äh wollte ich noch, das ziehe ich mir noch so ein. Und was ich aber sehr spannend fand, kurz nach der Veröffentlichung des Podcast tauchte dann äh auf einer Webseite etwas auf, was nämlich genau meiner,
These äh widerspricht. Und zwar ähm.
Haben, gibt es da eine Visualisierung? Jetzt habe ich irgendwie den falschen Link geklickt. Eine Visualisierung von den weltweiten Protesten. Also es ist eine,
äh eine Karte mit einer Zeitleiste, also man sieht die Weltkarte,
und dann läuft die Zeit so von irgendwie neunzehnhundertneunundsiebzig bis zweitausend sonst was durch. Und immer da, wo ein Protest ist, war, ja, laut Erfassung der Autoren, ähm ploppt dann mal kurz so ein äh Kreis auf,
und äh die Kreise sind, glaube ich, in der Größe, ähm wenn es ein kleiner Kreis ist, wenn es ein kleiner Protest und je größer war, glaube ich, die Teilnehmerzahl oder so. Und jetzt siehst du, wenn das so von in die neunziger Jahre kommt, das ist so siebziger bis Neunziger fast gleich. Und jetzt
mehr wird's langsam mehr, ne? Jetzt so Mitte der Neunziger, man sieht immer mehr Punkte gleichzeitig,
Aggregiert ist das dann nur also auf Monatsbasis und jetzt geht's los so, zweitausend wenn Jahrtausendwende und es werden immer mehr.
Das ist die Frage, wie wie umfangreich jetzt Proteste auch erfasst werden, ne? Also.
Erstmal eine Frage, wie äh wie hat die Person oder wie haben die Leute, die das gemacht haben, Protest erfasst? Wie haben sie ähm,
erfasst, das ist ein Protest irgendwo gab, ja, also haben sie irgendwie eine Googlesuche gemacht oder äh sonst was, aber wenn man einfach mal nur
sagen wir mal, sagt, dass ihre Datenerfassung vielleicht für die letzten fünfzehn Jahre reliabel war, dann sieht man da schon immer noch eine riesige Zunahme zwischen, sagen wir mal, äh äh achtundneunzig und zwanzig dreizehn oder so, ne?
Also die die Proteste weltweit nehmen zu. Was ja echt war interessant ist.
Proteste gegen was.
Grundsätzlich überhaupt erstmal. Also, dass es Proteste gibt. Ja, also
Antiglobalisierung, Antig, sonst was, ja? Oder überhaupt, ja, also kann ja auch sein, dass die Leute gegen äh
gegen eine Steuererhöhung protestieren, ja? Also überhaupt dessen der geäußert wird gesellschaftlich sehr interessantes,
sehr interessantes ähm.
Also diesmal ist mal ganz spannend. Ähm wie gesagt, müsste man sich musste man nochmal die Datenerfassung genau sich anschauen,
und ähm dann kann man sich ja überlegen, was was der die Schlussfolgerung davon ist. Also wenn die Leute mutiger zu protestieren oder ähm das wäre ja so ähm meine These ähm.
Dass sie dass ihnen nur noch der Protest bleibt. Also Protest ist ja auch so ein bisschen das das letzte das letzte Resort.
Allgemeine Verzweiflung heraus.
Na, eine nicht eine allgemeine Verzweiflung, aber so, dass ähm dass du immer mehr Menschen hast, die mit den gesellschaftlichen oder politischen Entwicklungen in ihrem Land unzufrieden sind und nur noch,
oder zumindest so weit sind, dass sie protestieren. Ja, das ist ja äh.
Ja gut, kann man jetzt für dich, also finde das jetzt ein bisschen schwierig äh aus so einer einfachen Visualisierung,
Dinge abzuleiten ohne jetzt die Daten wirklich genau zu kennen, wie die abgegrenzt sind und ich meine, man könnte auch argumentieren, dass die äh zunehmende Vernetzung, also jetzt gar nicht mal nur mit Internet, das natürlich auch, aber auch,
Mobiltelefone et cetera natürlich erheblich dazu beigetragen haben, dass sich Protest auch,
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes organisieren kann, ja? Und das sozusagen ein Protest natürlich auch dann ausbleibt, wenn er sich nicht organisiert bekommt, auch wenn die Umstände, ja, die man beklagt, äh da äh bereits,
in einem unerwünschten Zustand sich befinden.
Viele verschiedene Faktoren werden zu diesen Ergebnis geführt haben, kann man lange drüber äh äh protestieren, sage ich schon,
philosophieren aber spannend ist auf jeden Fall die Diagnose oder das Ergebnis selber eigentlich erstmal konterintuitiv ist,
Ähm und dann habe ich noch rausgesucht zu dem zu der welcher sagte Finanzkrise kann man viel mehr sehen. Ähm,
wie Politik heute ähm funktioniert oder nicht. Da gibt's einen äh Podcast schon von vor längerer Zeit bei den Kollegen von Metronaut, die sich da mit einem,
ähm Volkswirt unterhalten haben über ähm,
Finanz Euro und Bankenkrise. Mirko Knoche heißt ja. Und äh das ist äh,
Das war ganz interessant, sich das mal anzuhören. Ist auch schon etwas älter.
Okay. Dann kommen wir vielleicht hier zum Brot und Butter dieses Programms. Ja. Was ist denn passiert?
Ähm,
Also es gab eine es gab eine ganz schöne, ganz schöne Meldung. Ein Fall, der schon, der schon sehr, sehr viele äh der seit ja über dreieinhalb Jahren jetzt so die Menschen beschäftigt ist, ähm
zu einem finalen Abschluss bekommen und ähm zwar geht es dabei um eine Abmahnung. Und zwar hat eine so eine Abmahnkanzlei irgendwie am vierten Januar zweitausendzehn,
festgestellt, dass über äh das System edunkie, kennst du noch? Ähm
Film heruntergeladen und bereitgestellt wurde und es handelte sich dabei um ein den Film mit dem Titel Kategorie C deutsche Hooligans, ein Hooligan-Film, ja,
und
äh dann gehen sie die, was sie dann so machen, ist, also sie stellen fest, diese IP-Adresse bietet das an, dann gehen sie zum Provider, lassen sie sich die IP-Adresse geben, dann schicken sie eine Abmahnung hin und sagen, hier, du hast ähm Rechte verletzt und wollen dann, wollten dann jetzt sechshundertfünfzig Euro haben, ja?
Und dieser Brief ging an eine ähm pflegebedürftige äh Rentnerin, die,
Kein Computer besaß und auch kein Router. Die hatte einen Internetanschluss, weil ihr Ex-Freund öfter mal bei ihr mit seinem Laptop war und,
dann da Internet.
Internet brauchte.
Genau, mit dem weiß ich aber sie hat irgendwie im halben Jahr nicht mehr zusammen und entsprechend hatte sie
zahlte sie jetzt noch irgendwie für diesen Internetanschluss, war aber nicht in der Lage, den zu nutzen. Ja, sie hatte keinen Computer und dies hatte halt dieses blöde Internet, ja.
Und ähm dann hat sie natürlich irgendwie gesagt, ja nee, hier äh ich möchte das nicht bezahlen, ja?
Und ähm.
Ende zweitausendelf äh wurde sie dann vom Amtsgericht Amtsgericht München äh dazu verurteilt, die Abmahnkosten plus Zinsen zu zahlen,
weil die IP-Adresse war ja schließlich ihre und ähm darüber war eben dieser Film angeboten worden und da kommt jetzt der das große,
Thema natürlich auf, was was für die Richter da auch eine Rolle gespielt haben muss und zwar Störerhaftung, ja?
Also es geht genau darum, es könnte ja jetzt jeder behaupten, ich habe keinen Computer, da könnte ja jeder kommen,
Und um genau das zu verhindern, gibt's äh gilt in,
einschlägiger Rechtssprechung, diese Idee der Störerhaftung, dass also jemand, der ein Internetanschluss hat.
Letztendlich auch dafür haftet, was andere Menschen mit diesem Internetanschluss machen
da gibt's dann das geht regelmäßig soweit das irgendwelche Rentner oder oder was heißt Rentner ist jetzt so ich sag jetzt Rentner weil das Leuten ihre WLANs geknackt werden und darüber falsch gegangen betrieben wird und sie dann irgendwelche riesen Abmahnungen bekommen und sagen ich weiß noch nicht mal was.
Was das ist? Ja ja.
Ist und ich interessiere mich auch gar nicht für Hooligans, ja.
Ja, also das ist ein ist kein seltener Fall, ja, oder äh wir erinnern uns, wir hatten ja auch darüber gesprochen.
Herr Geier, also die Zunahme der Proteste, ja, am Ende sind das alles so Rentner, die sich Hooligan Filme anschauen und jetzt ab dumme Ideen kommen.
Ähm so, also das das Phänomen gibt's immer öfter und da gibt's natürlich.
Hatte sie den Arzt, Entschuldigung, hatte sie denn überhaupt, also war dieser Internetanschluss nur nur aufm Papier und da war dann gar kein Gerät mehr oder lief da schon noch ein Router? Also unten WL.
Laut der Artikel auf Zeit hatte sie noch nicht mal einen Router. Wenn sie aber keinen Router gehabt hätte, hätte sie auch keine IP-Adresse bekommen.
Die Christian nur, wenn dein Modem mit dem,
mit dem auf welcher Ebene das passiert weiß ich dann gar nicht. Ja im Rechenzentrum wahrscheinlich, ne? Also irgendwo wird dann halt dir eine IP-Adresse zugeteilt,
und äh dieser, das muss ja stattgefunden haben oder vermutlich stattgefunden haben
Denn jetzt gibt's ja mehrere Überlegungen. Wie kommt's, wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass die Rentnerin jetzt keinen Computer hatte? Dann also entweder hatte sie irgendwie ein offenes WLAN oder so oder äh jemand hatte am irgendwie zwei zwei Kabel dran geklemmt und hat ihren
theoretischen Anschluss benutzt oder so ähm oder es gab ähm hm.
Sagen wir mal vielleicht ein Fehler bei der Feststellung, wer zu welchem Zeitpunkt welcher IP-Adresse hatte,
Ja, also dieser dieser Prozess der Zuordnung ähm eventuell gab's dann Zahlendreher oder oder vielleicht
Ne, gabs mehrere Personen mit dem Nachnamen und derjenige, der die Auskunft erteilt hat, ist in der Zeile verrutscht, sofern die Auskunft zu diesem Zeitpunkt zweitausendzehn noch nicht automatisiert war, wovon ich eigentlich ausgegangen wäre. Also
nichts Genaues weiß man nicht. Fest steht, die Frau hatte keinen Computer und entsprechend war sie das jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht. Äh deswegen will ich jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen von diesem Fall abstrahieren. Weil es gibt's regelmäßig. Also klassischer Fall WG, ja?
Wer war es jetzt? Plötzlich ist seine äh eine File-Sharing-Abmahnung. Ja, wer war's? Äh und dann ist vielleicht der der Anschlussinhaber,
gerade im Erasmus-Jahr und sowieso nicht da, ne? Aber äh die klassische Rechtsprechung,
ist eben das letztendlich die dann als Störer Huff, also dass sie einer Störerhaftung unterliegen und das ist ähnlich wie bei ähm,
wie bei Fahrzeugen, ja, also wenn du jetzt ähm wenn jetzt äh wenn ich mein Fahrzeug verleihe und damit wird jemand geblitzt.
Dann ähm und ich sage, ich weiß nicht, wer das ist, dann habe ich mit einer Konsequenz zu rechnen. Also entweder,
die sich dann denken können, dass sich Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht in Anspruch nehmen und dass das deshalb ein Verwandter oder sowas von mir ist. Oder sie werden mir dann eine Fahrtenbuchauflage machen oder so, ne? Aber das heißt,
endlich haftet man dafür, wenn man solche Dinge anderen Menschen zugänglich macht.
Das wäre vielleicht auch was für Internetanschlüsse, ne, dass man dann Fahrtenbuch führt.
Fachfahrtenbuch für IP-Paket, ne.
Ja wo haben sie denn da entlang gerautet.
Und aber das das das Themenfeld ist natürlich ziemlich komplex, weil jetzt gibt's ja gerade wieder äh also seit Jahren sind die eigentlich in Medien, die ähm Easyboxen von Vodafone,
Algorithmus, wo sie im Prinzip aus der Geräte ist, einerseits ihr Netzwerknamen,
Netzwerknamen und das Kennwort generieren und das ist öffentlich. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt im Besitz dieses Codes ist, den,
den kriegt man halt so, ne, findet man. Ähm dann macht man, setzt man sich irgendwie hin, sieht, man hat kein WLAN, swift halt ein bisschen, guckt so, ah, wo sind denn hier Easy Boxen?
Ja? Und dann sieht man natürlich auch im äh im Sniffer die Meckadressen von den Dingern,
Und dann gibt man einfach einmal die Meckadresse ein und kriegt den den Netzwerknamen, gut, den sieht man ja ohnehin und das dazugehörige, die Ford Passwort. Kann sich anmelden und ist im Internet, ja? Das ist ein Problem, was seit längerer Zeit für wo davon besteht. Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem für die Störerhaftung.
Ja? Und da wird aber wird aber jetzt, da sind dann teilweise Urteile, dass dann gesagt wird, na ja, ähm es ist halt, du hast deine Sorgfaltspflicht verletzt, wenn du dein WLAN die Passwort nicht änderst, ja?
Ähm oder ähnliche Probleme. Also es sind, man kann sich vorstellen, es gibt sehr, sehr viele Fälle, in denen man ähm.
Wirklich seine die Kontrolle darüber verliert, wer den eigenen Internetanschluss nutzt,
Also ich ich nutze meinen auch mit mehreren Personen und dann geben die teilweise geben die den mal weiter. Jetzt überwache ich mein jetzt die ganze Zeit und merke sofort, wenn da jemand drin ist, äh der da nicht reingehört
und dann sind sie immer ganz verwundert und scharren mit den Füßen, ja, weil die auf einmal irgendwie das halbe Haus äh wieder bei mir im Netzwerk ist, ja. Ähm.
Man sieht also eigentlich kann man im normalen Bürger diese Sorgfalt kaum aufbürden,
Dafür zu sorgen, dafür, da wirklich in Zeiten von von WLANs und WLAN Unsicherheiten für Sorge zu tragen, dass diese Dinger äh sicher sind. Vor allem jetzt nicht nach äh Berliner Rentnerin, die gar keinen Computer hat.
Das jetzt ausgegangen?
Ja, genau, wird spannender. Also, Störerhaftung, ich wollte nur kurz,
als Seitennotiz sagen, beim letzten äh Chaos Communication Kongress habe ich ja einen,
Vortrag gemacht mit Ulfmeier und,
Markus Beckerdal wo es dann auch um die Störerhaftung ging und den den Gesetzesvorschlag von digitale Gesellschaft um um diese diesen Problem dieses Problems Herr zu werden.
Denn das behindert natürlich auch so diese ganzen Ideen wie Freifunk oder überhaupt einfach mal sein WLAN,
frei zugänglich zu machen, ja? Spreche ja eigentlich nichts gegen ähm WLAN zum aufzumachen für für Leute, die vorbeikommen, für Nachbarn, für Freunde, sich sowas zu teilen. Ähm,
aber die das Risiko, was man eben als Bürger dabei eingeht, ist, dass man am Ende so eine Situation ist, wie diese äh Dame hier. So, was passiert? Ähm,
In erster Instanz, Amtsgericht München wird sie verurteilt, den ganzen Kram äh zu zahlen, obwohl jetzt irgendwie völlig unklar ist, was passiert ist, aber es ist ganz offensichtlich nicht ihr ähm ihr Vergehen, geschweige denn ihr Versäumnis war.
Ähm dann wurde schon im April,
beim Berufungsgericht, das war dann, glaube ich, Berliner Landgericht oder sowas. Ähm dieses Urteil ähm.
Wieder quasi in den.
Intuitiv sinnvolleren, in die intuitiv sinnvollere Perspektive revidiert, nämlich, dass die Frau nicht Schuld ist und nicht zu zahlen hat,
und das Gericht ließ aber die Revision zu und diese Revision hat dann die Epic Media AG, also der Kläger,
Und damit wäre das Ganze vor den Bundesgerichtshof gegangen und.
Das stand also jetzt aus, das heißt, die arme Frau, ja, die nichts, die noch nicht mal einen Computer hatte,
zitterte jetzt quasi vorm vor einer äh Auseinandersetzung vom Bundesgerichtshof und die sind natürlich äh nicht so günstig, ja, weil man da ja entsprechende Anwälte braucht, die da überhaupt zugelassen sind und den ganzen Fu
Und jetzt hat diese die Epic Media AG,
Klage zurückgezogen. Das heißt, sie akzeptieren das Urteil der zweiten Instanz und sagen, wir geben uns der guten Frau gegenüber geschlagen. Das ist für die Frau jetzt gut, weil die muss nicht ähm die sechshundertfünfzig Euro bezahlen,
Das ist allerdings schlecht für die Aussicht auf Änderung der Gesetzeslage, weil der BGH ist, wo es äh höchstes Gericht in der äh Frage,
hätte ja dann eventuell sagen können, dass die Gesetzeslage etwas anderes vorsieht oder dass die Gesetzeslage geändert werden muss, weil sie so nicht in Ordnung ist. Und diese Chance wurde also jetzt ein ähm.
Im Prinzip vertan. Hm, insofern.
Ja, kann man sagen. Trotzdem ist es natürlich gut, weil dieses, weil dieses Urteil ja jetzt da ist und da das man das auch sieht und ich glaube auch nicht, dass jemand ähm in so weit gehen würde
äh also da werden die jetzt auch blöd gewesen, dass von von hohes Bundesgericht zu bringen
Aber an dieser, in diesem Problem fällt der Störerhaftung muss sich irgendwie mal langsam was tun. Und das ist auch eines der,
eines der wichtigen Felder für ja die zukünftige digitale Gesellschaft, ne?
Ja, Rentner sind ja auch durchaus eine Zielgruppe für die CDU. Da können sie ja mal was Wahlprogramm reinschreiben.
Wollen, wir wollen wir wollen Rentnerinnen nicht länger mit äh.
Dem sechzigsten Lebensjahr keine Störerhaftung mehr oder was?
So habe ich das jetzt nicht gemeint.
Also Störerhaft, ne, aus
Gründen ein Problem, das geht ja dann auch weiter irgendwie, wenn du als wenn dein Rechner Teil eines Bot Netzes geworden ist, weil er infiziert wurde und du dann da unfreiwillig Teil von von Hacking-Angriffen wirst oder so, das sind alles ähm,
alles äh Probleme, die nicht äh nicht kleinzureden sind. Das also jetzt mal zu dem Fall, wo also eine äh.
Rentnerin sich ein Hooligan Film runtergeladen hat und danach alle Beweismittel inklusive des Computers vernichtet hat. So muss man das ja sehen, ne.
Die haben toll ein teures MacBook Pro Retina gleich irgendwie in Schredder geworfen, da ist der Brief kam. Na gut.
Na gut. Ähm dann kommen wir zu den zu den äh Fragen des, der Geheimdienste wieder.
Ja, da sind mal wieder neue Dokumente aufgetaucht. Ja, wobei jetzt angeblich.
Ja, wobei jetzt wird's ja echt. Genau, jetzt, jetzt ist aufgetaucht, äh also Washington Post veröffentlichte,
dreiundvierzig Seiten aus einem insgesamt hundertsiebenundachtzig Seiten langen,
Hundertachtundsiebzig Seiten der Hand, nicht übertreiben. Hundertachtundsiebzig Seiten Dokument von AdWords Snowden,
Und das die interessante Seitennotiz ist, auf die dreiundvierzig Seiten von den hundertsiebenundachtzig sind sie.
Du merkst das jedes Mal, ne?
Ich bin hier der Korrektor.
Hundertachtundsiebzig Seiten sind sie gekommen, indem sie sich mit der äh US-Regierung auseinandergesetzt haben, gesagt haben, guck mal hier, wir haben hier so ein Leak,
euch was soll man denn davon mal veröffentlichen?
Und äh dann hat die äh die Obama-Administration gesagt, ja, guck mal hier, die dreiundvierzig Seiten von den hundertachtundsiebzig könnt ihr,
Veröffentlichen die anderen ähm immerhin hundert, boah, auf hundertfünfunddreißig.
Ja.
Seiten ähm.
Die bitte nicht.
Die bitte nicht um die Quellen und Methoden der US-Geheimdienste zu schützen.
Nationale Sicherheit.
Interessant, ausgerechnet Quellen und Methoden sind ja genau das, was hier Thema des Skandals sind, ne. Ähm was stand auf den Seiten?
Da ging's hauptsächlich um die Aktivitäten und wie ihre Budgets so verteilt sind. Da gab's dann irgendwie ja irgendwie die CIA, kriegt mehr als die NSA und ähm dann war da der schöne Satz drin äh wir investieren in,
Wie würde man übersetzen.
Ja, ich sage mal, grundlegend ohne dass es jetzt im Wortsein übersetzt ist, ne.
Im grundlegend neue.
Also man könnte es auch als Revolutionär äh übersetzen, ich weiß nicht. Kryptoanalyse.
Wir wir in wir investieren in eine äh,
grundbrechende Kryptoanalytische Fähigkeiten, um äh bösartige Kryptographie
zu besiegen und Internetverkehr zu nutzen,
Das könnte was. Also sie arbeiten offensichtlich mit einem großen Budget daran, eine Verschlüsselung,
Knacken zu können, die im Moment als nicht knackbar ist, so könnte man das ungefähr rauslesen.
Ähm.
Und weiter geht's, dass sie irgendwie einundzwanzig Prozent des Geheimdienstbudgets, also ähm elf Milliarden.
Dem widmen, bei dem fünfunddreißigtausend Angestellte,
der NSA und der äh äh bewaffneten Kräfte an ähm Kryptoanalyse arbeiten.
Also das sind jetzt fünfunddreißigtausend Angestellte Code Knacker.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Fünfunddreißigtausend. In Deutschland arbeiten da wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal fünfunddreißig dran.
Ja. Ja, also ich, ja, die Krypto. Na ja, sagen wir mal so, die die Anzahl der Personen, die an sowas mit,
mit überhaupt einer Aussicht auf Erfolg arbeiten, ist schon sehr, sehr klein.
Und klar, es geht natürlich oder es gibt geht vermutlich äh ja, um AIS oder so, ne. Also.
Einundzwanzig Prozent des Intelligence Budgets. Ein Fünftel der Geheimdienstausgaben werden darauf gelegt Krypto zu knacken.
Also ich würde sagen, geile Krypto, ne? Also es ist,
schon so ein äh Schulterklopfer für die Jungs, die sich das mal ausgedacht haben, die übrigens,
war ja die NSA oder also die war ja da war ja da mit dran beteiligt solche Sachen zu machen. Aber okay, sie sagen natürlich jetzt nicht an welchem enggriptischen Standard sie da
knabbern oder was oder vielleicht auch an vielen gleichzeitig. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die fünfunddreißigtausend sich es gibt ja mehrere als äh ziemlich sicher geltende äh Schifffriermethoden und ähm,
ja, man wird jetzt sehen an Werder, also sie werden sicherlich nicht alle an einem, an einem an einer äh an einem Seifer arbeiten, sondern wahrscheinlich an allen.
Muss man anders auszudrücken. Krypto ist ein dickes Thema,
ja? Also äh die Schlapphüte sind jetzt im Wesentlichen jetzt nicht dabei, sich die ganze Zeit hinter Laternen zu äh verstecken und irgendwelchen Leuten durch windige äh Straßen zu äh äh folgen, sahen.
Dieser, wie soll man das nennen, dieser Geheimdienstkrieg ist spielt sich im Wesentlichen elektronisch ab heutzutage,
Interessant finde ich auch dieses Detail, dass die Washington Post sich da so mit der äh,
Regierung abstimmt, was sie denn jetzt da veröffentlichen und was sie denn da nicht äh veröffentlichen sollen. Wird jetzt irgendwie böse sein und sagen, naja,
Jeff Bezos will ja nicht seine äh seine Deals mit den Geheimdiensten äh äh verlieren, aber ich glaube, so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Das kommt dann wahrscheinlich erst noch. Ähm klingt jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal ein bisschen merkwürdig. Vielleicht nicht ganz so merkwürdig, wenn man's sich nochmal genauer anschaut, was da gelaufen ist.
Es ist auf jeden ich denke, dass daher auch kommt, dass,
Also mich würde natürlich interessieren, woran arbeiten sie, wenn also die Information, welche welche Methoden sie gerade knacken wollen, ist ja im Prinzip eine sehr wichtige, weil das heißt, dass sie es hieße, dass sie es im Moment noch nicht können, ja?
Ich frage mich jetzt auch, wo kommt denn bitte dieses Dokument her?
Also äh es hieß ja, es sei von Snowden, aber Snowden arbeitet ja nicht mit der Washington Post zusammen, sondern mit dem Guardian und der Guardian wiederum äh will sich ja jetzt die Arbeit teilen mit der New York Times.
Ja, ist ein bisschen komisch.
Ja auch neulich schon äh Veröffentlichungen, wo dann, ich weiß nicht, lief das dann über Wiki Leaks, die äh,
dann die quasi die Verschwörungstheorie äh in die Welt gesetzt haben, hier sein Dokumente unter seinem Namen veröffentlicht worden. Genau, das bezog sich auf diese.
Veröffentlichung independent.
Israel, entschuldige mich Israel, der britische Basen im Nahen Osten, zum Abhören, wo nicht genau gesagt wurde, wo die sind,
und diese Dokumente äh seien halt auch aus der Snowdenquelle und äh jetzt weiß ich nicht ganz genau, welchen
Öffentlichkeitsweg, das äh gegangen ist, ob das irgendwie von Snowden, von Guardian kam. Also irgendjemand hat auf jeden Fall in Frage gestellt, dass diese Dokumente tatsächlich äh von Snowden waren und.
Sogar noch noch äh krasser als es war, es lief so, dass der dass diese Veröffentlichung im Independent eben jetzt eine, dadurch, dass sie wirklich dann,
bisschen tiefgreifend war. Eine war, wo man hätte sagen können, die gefährdet jetzt die nationale Sicherheit, ja und
die Verschwörungstheorie wäre jetzt quasi, dass der, dass der independent absichtlich sowas macht, um nachher sagen zu können, hier der Snoden ist ein schädlicher Knabe. Gleichzeitig hat der Snowden aber sofort gesagt, das weiß ich nicht, ist nicht von mir,
Und ähm dann hat der independent aber noch geschrieben, ja und hier, das sind die Sachen, die der Guardian äh irgendwie zerstören musste und so. Also die die machen, jetzt wird's halt,
ganz klar so äh Food, ne, also FUD, vier. So, jetzt gibt's irgendwie so Tritt Trittbretts oder so, also das wird jetzt noch richtig spannend, aber da weiß man gar nicht, wo irgendwas herkommt.
Ähm aber also da ging's dann um die Anzapferei von Kabeln hauptsächlich. Ne, das war jetzt wieder Thema. Mir ist ein bisschen unklar wieso
Also ich hab's jetzt nicht, vielleicht ist mir ja was entgangen, aber ich habe jetzt nicht festgestellt, wo da jetzt wirklich was Neues war. Also außer, dass halt mehr belegt war, wo es also darum ging,
dass der, dass die Briten mit ihrem und aus die Australier irgendwie wie gesagt an mehreren Unterseekabeln hängen und da ging's natürlich um diejenigen, die eben auch auf deren Boden sind. Ähm.
Eine Menge sind, nicht alle, aber eine Menge.
Sind, ja, also irgendwie äh namentlich genannt wurden da, äh die TAT.
Telegraphie, glaube ich, dreizehn vierzehn,
Zieh, W dreizehn, Atlantic Crossing One, also da müsste man dann nochmal auf der äh auf Gregs Cable Map äh nochmal schauen, wo die alle liegen. Ist jetzt vielleicht auch eher,
sekundär, der interessantere Teil bei der, bei, bei dieser Veröffentlichung, äh, war dann eben,
dass sie gesagt haben, ja, kooperierende Firmen, British, Telekom, Level drei, ViaTL, Interruit, Horizon und Vodafone,
ähm die mit deren Kooperation,
dass eben möglich ist, diese Kabel anzuschnorcheln. Und diese Kabel ähm gehören,
Betreiberkonsort ziehen. Ja, also es gibt jetzt dann, entschließen sich mehrere Telkos zusammen und sagen, komm mal, wenn wir hier ein Kabel durch den.
Durch den Teich legen, dann ist das doch toll, ja? Und ähm dann gibt's also quasi so ja Konsortien, die diese Kabel dann
äh betreiben, unterhalten und so. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, hey, da wollen wir irgendwie unseren äh Schnorchel bei euch mal dranhalten. Da muss man natürlich irgendwo mit irgendjemanden da sprechen. Das war ja schon
seit längerer Zeit jetzt klar, dass das auch schwierig ohne äh Kooperation ähm.
Möglich ist. Es sei denn, man hat ganz viele U-Boote mit Biegekoppeln, aber da habe ich ja schon gesagt, dass ich das für, ja, unwahrscheinlich halte.
TAT dreizehn.
Nicht. Ja, deshalb habe ich mich gerade versprochen. Ich hatte gehofft, das merkt keiner.
Ich wunderte mich schon.
Ähm ja, gut, kann man jetzt, also,
Interessante eben, die Firmen, die da mitmachen und die,
Das Interessante oder die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, unter welchen Bedingungen,
kooperieren diese Firmen, ja? Es gab dann direkt Anfragen bei Deutsche Telekom, weil bei zwei von den betroffenen Kabeln saß dann auch wieder die deutsche Telekom mit im Betreiberkonsortium, dann wurde Telekom-Sprecher hinzitiert und der hat gesagt, nein, wissen ja, machen dann nix so, wir
haben damit nichts zu tun
jetzt ist halt die Frage, ob da irgendjemand was mit zu tun hat und äh wie es auch immer aussieht, ja? Tatsache oder die offensichtliche Tatsache ist, dass es da was, äh dass da jemand was mit zu tun hat,
und ähm dass die das im Zweifelsfall, wenn sie es machen.
Kostenlos machen. Oder zumindest nicht freiwillig.
Kann man sich ja denken, dass da irgendeine Form von, sagen wir mal,
ja oder überhaupt erstmal eine Motivation hergestellt werden muss bei den Unternehmen das zu tun. Die Motivation kann natürlich einerseits sein, dass man sie.
Geschäftsführer jetzt nicht in den Kerker schmeißt.
Genau, dass man sie einer offenen Drohung oder nannt, na?
Würden wir im Falle einer Kollaboration auch auf Foltermaßnahmen verzichten.
Nein, das kannst du ja anders machen, also wir hatten ja schon, ich glaube, vor zwei, drei Folgen habe ich ja mal von diesem äh Menschen da gesprochen, der nachher mit der Steuerbehörden größere Probleme bekommen hatte. Ähm dann,
geht's ja auch um so Deals wie Frequenzvergabe oder sowas, ne. Da möchte man ja dann auch die Zukunft des Unternehmens gesichert sehen. Das wäre natürlich schade. Ähm und ähnliche Dinge. Was dann noch ähm,
Was sich dann nämlich rausstellte weiteres League ähm.
Dass die Abteilung, also die Abteilung von der NSA, die mit den Betreibern zusammenarbeitet, Betreiber in dem Fall jetzt Netzbetreiber oder auch Plattformbetreiber, also Facebook oder äh British Telekom oder was. Ähm.
Die sind also die heißt Special Source Operations und das sind so die Leute, die diesen Kontakt pflegen, ja? Und die haben,
ähm Geld gezahlt an Provider. An Plattformbetreiber. Und bestätigt wurde das schon von Yahoo.
Also Plattform Provider, so was wie Facebook, sowas wie äh Yahoo, Social Networks, leider da so Daten, wo sie eben auch spezifische plattformspezifische Daten gerne direkt geliefert bekommen, äh äh wollen, damit sie das nicht alles erst abhören müssen,
Man lässt einfach sich das auch gleich äh geheimdienst kompatibel übermitteln. Das finde ich ist ja auch wirklich so eine so eine besonders,
unglaubliche äh Form der Verflechtung,
diese ganzen Privatunternehmen mittlerweile äh äh in so einer engen Leine gehalten werden,
sie sich auf sowas auch einlassen müssen. Ich meine, das hat ja dann letztlich sogar auch also abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich das Vertrauen der.
Kunden sind das ja in den meisten Fällen, sind das ja gar nicht die Kunden, sondern das ist ja nur die User
Also zumindest das Vertrauen der User damit schwer erschüttert wird. Im Zweifelsfall halt auch der Kunden. Sollte sich da tatsächlich mal um Businessmodelle handeln, wo die Leute vielleicht auch für ihre Dienstleistungen
was zahlen, ja? Und das dann aber trotzdem quasi diese Firmen noch gezwungen werden, quasi den Dienst zu doppeln und dann noch nicht mal drüber reden zu dürfen.
Genau das ist sie, die Andere, die Anna ist vielleicht noch drauf kommen wollte, also der spezifische im spezifischen Fall ging es darum, dass der ähm Fisk,
Foren Intelligence Court sagte, ey, ihr müsst mal ein bisschen besser identifizieren. Ihr habt ja ein bisschen zu viele
Amerikaner mit drin. Und Amerikaner dürfte ja nicht überwachen, liebe NSA. Und ähm diese inländischen Kollateralschäden, sage ich jetzt mal, äh die würden wir ganz gerne ein bisschen reduziert sehen. Und dann haben die NSA gesagt, ja, das müssen wir irgendwie mit Hilfe der
Der Anbieter selber machen und ähm wenn die dann da irgendwie investieren müssen
dann äh müssen wir den natürlich auch äh diese Kosten erstatten. So und wie gesagt, ja bestätigt Geld zu bekommen zu haben, viele andere ähm,
haben da jetzt erstmal die also haben da jetzt keinen Kommentar zu abgegeben und Googles Kommentar war irgendwie so ja, wenn die NSA uns endlich mal erlauben würde über das zu sprechen, was wir machen würden, sicherlich viele Vorwürfe
oder viele Verdächtigungen sich hier auch enthärten. Ist das ein Begriff in kann man so sagen? Also.
Na ja.
Wenn, wenn sie's erlaubt bekommen würden.
Ich denke jetzt mal nicht, dass die finanziellen Anreize für diese Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit äh so groß sind, dass so ein Unternehmen darauf nicht verzichten möchte. Aber auch im im Falle dieser äh äh,
Kontinental äh Lichtwellenleiter, Kabel ähm,
war dann auch die Rede von Aufträgen, sowohl in der Hardware und Softwareentwicklung, die dann die beteiligten Unternehmen,
daraus abgegriffen haben. Aber das sind ja dann doch eher für solche riesen Konzerne Peanuts. Also insofern glaube ich, der finanzielle Anreiz ist da nicht der Einzige
Und das ist ja eine weitere Entwicklung der letzten Woche, dass wir,
wieder mehr über die Gag-Orders erfahren haben, ne? Also über die von dir gerade schon angesprochenen ähm Verschwiegenheitsverpflichtungen,
Ähm und da gab's also dieser, diese Gag-Orders sind ja auch Teil der,
Bekannten, ominösen und gefürchteten National Security Letters. Also der Briefe, in denen die US-Behörden von einer, von einem Plattformanbieter.
Nutzerdaten verlangen. Und in diesen Briefen,
Die Verpflichtung aussprechen, du darfst nicht darüber sprechen. Dass das jetzt hier passiert. Was ja in dem von Anne schon letzte Mal angesprochenen Fall von,
Nick Maril, dann äh dazu geführt hat, dass der sieben Jahre äh Rechtsstreit hatte,
Um sich gegen so eine National Security Letter überhaupt zu Wert zu setzen, weil er als allererstes sich mal erklagen musste, dass er überhaupt mit,
Also,
Dass er darüber, ob mit jemandem sprechen darf und zum Beispiel auch Sorge hatte, ob er eventuell sich schon irgendwie in den Knast bringt, wenn er darüber mit einem Anwalt spricht, weil er darf, steht ja, darf mit Imam darüber sprechen. Also völlig,
skurrile Bedingungen in diesen National Security Letters. Was mich daran erinnerte, das ist ja alles nichts Neues. Wie gesagt, den diesen National Security Letter Sache, das war von äh,
von Nick Mary, der der Vortrag war beim siebenundzwanzig C drei,
wo er dann endlich darüber sprechen durfte nach sieben Jahren. Das heißt, die Praxis war da schon sieben oder acht Jahre alt. Ähm,
ähnlich war das bei den äh Twitter Sapinas, die ähm.
An bekannterweise Twitter gingen und die äh Nutzeraccounts von Rob Gongry, Birgit hier, Jacob Apple Baum,
trafen. Jeremy war auch noch dabei, ne, oder? Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Weiß jetzt nur von den Dreien. Mhm.
Das waren, glaube ich, nur die drei. Ähm in denen es dann darum ging,
Ich habe leider den, ich habe die Briefe nicht mehr gefunden, ich habe die äh irgendwo zu Hause rumliegen, als als Dateien irgendwie. Ähm wo dann so gesagt wurde, ja hallo, ach so, Julian Assange, Bradley Menning war noch dabei. Die die beiden fehlten, es waren doch fünf,
Ähm und wo dann gesagt wurde, ja wir wollen gerne folgende Daten haben Doppelpunkt. Und dann irgendwie so,
Ja äh die Adresse unter der der Account registriert ist, die konnten die zur Zahlung genutzt werden, die Zugangsmessage History. Einmal einmal so alles, was ihr so habt. Und interessanterweise ist es ja ein bisschen.
Idiotisch von Twitter ähm paymentredentials zu verlangen, weil man bei Twitter ja gar nicht bezahlen kann, selbst wenn man möchte,
Ähm was ja schon darauf was ja schon ein starkes Indiz darauf war dahingehend war, dass es sich dabei um Serienbriefe handelte.
Als solche hinten aus dem Druck herausfallen und selbstverständlich auch an äh an Google und die anderen ähm Anbieter gingen,
die unter Umständen ihre Dienste dem betroffenen Personen zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Also.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall noch ein generelles Problem. Da wird sich wahrscheinlich auch so schnell äh nichts ändern,
Was es auf jeden Fall zeigt und was man hier herausziehen kann aus dieser etwas schwammigen Nachrichtenlage,
jetzt auch noch nichts Neues ist, aber man kann's, glaube ich, mal so zusammenfassen, so die Geheimdienste in den USA haben extrem,
starke Gesetzeslage oder zumindest äh entsprechende,
Entscheidungen im Rücken, die ihnen die Möglichkeit geben, ganz tief in diese äh Unternehmen hineinzugehen, ihnen auch Geld zu geben. Ähm das Ganze kriegt
aus meiner Perspektive auch noch eine andere Dimension. Da haben wir jetzt noch nicht so viel drüber gesprochen, aber das äh hat hier schon mal angedeutet.
Diese ganzen Cloud-Operations, dieser großen Provider, also in den zunehmenden Maßen natürlich auch sehr interessant für die Geheimdienste, weil irgendjemand, ich meine, irgendwo muss ja das Know-How äh so eine Abhör- äh Maßnahme zu machen, auch herkommen
und ähm ich glaube im Falle von Amazon gibt's da also durchaus auch Bestrebungen, diese Cloud-Infrastruktur ähm halt auch
mit Government äh Contracts zu betreiben. Was natürlich dann nochmal eine,
andere Abhängigkeit auch nochmal schafft, weil in dem Moment, wo natürlich ähm Aufträge des Staates äh winken, ja, was äh potenziell eine ganze Menge Leut, äh ganze Menge Geld
bedeuten kann,
Na ja, ist halt diese Verpflichtung auch so vielseitig. Du hast vorhin schon gesagt, na ja, so Frequenzvergabe und sone Sachen äh sind alles so äh äh Dinge, wo natürlich die Unternehmen es sich nicht verscherzen wollen. Also zumindest und vor allem.
Großen.
Und,
In den USA ist das ja alles Gesetz. Das ist ja gesetzlich geregelt. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, als wäre das eine Praxis, die irgendwie in einem Graubereich stattfinden würde,
Jetzt kommen wir überhaupt erstmal zu dem, was jetzt diese Woche rauskam. Und zwar hatte sich Google,
gegen einen National Security Letter gewehrt und spezifisch, die darin enthaltene Klause, dass sie nicht darüber sprechen dürfen,
und dieser Fall wurde verhandelt und,
Urteil wurde dann entsprechend geschwärzt und veröffentlicht,
Ja, also es wurde ein Urteil gesprochen, so und jetzt haben die Zensuren,
an einer Stelle den Firmennamen Google nicht,
Also vergessen zu schmerzen. Das heißt, aus dem Urteil ging dann hervor, dass die Betroffene der Betroffene äh Kläger in dem Fall eben Google war, die sich da gegen einen National Security Letter gewehrt haben?
Ja? Und vor Gericht mit dieser Einschätzung unterlegen sind. Das heißt, diese Praxis,
ist nicht illegal.
No. Die haben einfach das Maul zu halten. Nur, dass sie halt nicht so gut im Schmerzen sind.
Da weiß man halt jetzt nicht, ne? Also kann halt sein, dass da jemand gesagt hat, ach, probiere ich's mal.
Schlüsseligkeitsfehler kann man ja als Zensur auch mal passieren. Ich muss ja auch mal pinkeln, ja?
So nach dem Motto, wir können's euch jetzt nicht offiziell erlauben, aber äh wenn ihr unbedingt drauf besteht, dann äh bestätigen wir das jetzt mal hier durch die Blume hindurch. Ja, auch sehr schön, irgendwie nicht Schwärzung, ne.
Die Zensurenblume.
Ne, aber gut, wie gesagt, das Geheimnis war, äh, ich meine, es war ohnehin klar, ja, es war auch der Fall. Ich meine, ich glaube, das war Jacob Apple, warum wir das dann auch mehr oder weniger bekannt war, dass es bei äh Google diese Anfragen gab, das machen die,
Das läuft so und das ist legal nach US-Gesetzen, dass du nicht davon erfährst.
Dass diese Datenabfrage passiert. So.
Ciao,
Das nimmt kein Ende. Weitere Dokumente äh ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo die rauskamen. Auf jeden Fall äh sieht es ganz danach aus, als ob die USA mit ihren Geheimdiensten, glaube ich, auch die NSA, ne?
Äh in in die Lage, sich in die Lage versetzt hat von außen, dass äh den UN-Komplex in New York sich soweit zu erhacken, dass sie auch Zugriff hatten auf das Videotelefoniesystem des Hauses,
sehr schön, also man stellt sich das mal nur vor, ja, da äh,
disquatiert quasi so die internationale äh Diplomatie per Videokonferenz und äh den USA ist halt gelungen, da die Verschlüsselung auszuheben und sich im Prinzip in jedes Ge
einzuklinken, was sie dann wahrscheinlich auch gleich umfangreich aufgezeichnet haben. Kann man zumindest jetzt nur vermuten, aber,
so oder so. Das pikante daran ist, dass ähm während der sonst immer auch argumentiert wird, na ja,
Geheimdienste sind Geheimdienste, so sind sie halt, ja, die äh haben einen Auftrag, die müssen halt Informationen äh äh ranholen, das kann man ihnen jetzt nicht zum Vorwurf machen
Im Falle des Standortes UN, in New York allerdings ist es wohl, dass sich die USA ganz hochamtlich äh dazu verpflichtet haben, genau so etwas nicht zu tun,
Und äh ja,
trotzdem findet es halt statt, so viel kann man dann eben auch auf äh was auch die schriftlichen Zusagen von Geheimdiensten äh betrifft und Staaten, ja, äh es scheint dann doch nicht so weit äh her zu sein.
Das kümmert allerdings um sein Innenminister äh nicht. Der findet äh schön, dass er überhaupt noch Briefe kriegt. Oder?
Der findet das nicht so problematisch. Also die UN hat jetzt gesagt, sie verlangt jetzt von den USA eine Erklärung.
Der Friedrich hat seine ja schon bekommen, insofern.
Tauchte also gestern äh wieder in ich habe da jetzt nur den Artikel so gelesen in so einer ZDF-Sendung auf und sagte, ja, also.
Alles nicht so schlimm.
Nee, äh äh keine Spionage. Er will ja überhaupt erstmal wissen, wer dieser Snowden überhaupt ist.
Das das könnte ihm ja mal jemand sagen.
Die Rolle von AdWords Norden könne er erst einschätzen, wenn er weiß, wer Herr Snowden ist.
Ja, das äh da da sind wir natürlich jetzt noch nicht drauf, äh nicht dran, drauf gekommen, dass verstehst du? Vielleicht hat ihm einfach noch keiner eine Mail geschrieben.
Nein, komm, also das ist also das ist wirklich ein tragischer.
Ein bayerischer Politiker, der ist unter Umständen auch hilflos an der Stelle. Man muss auch einfach mal ein bisschen Mitleid haben.
Na ja, also wie wie gesagt, also das ist das ist nur noch ein tragischer Fall. Ähm also dass er sagt, äh.
Also weißt du, es kommt, Moment. Also Situationen, ne, wie jetzt allein, was ich jetzt gerade erzählt habe, ist ja nur in der letzten Woche gewesen, ja,
und am Ende einer solchen Woche setzt er sich ins Fernsehen und sagt, alle Aussagen von wurden überprüft,
Und die amerikanischen Geheimdienste spionieren uns nicht aus.
Wir wissen nicht, wer das ist, aber wir haben seine Aussagen überprüft.
Die Amerikaner haben seine Aussagen für uns überprüft.
So und dann sagt er.
Wir haben uns ein Fax geschickt.
Ach so, dann haben sie gesagt, dann haben sie ihm gesagt, ja äh hier äh Herr Friedrich, haben sie gelesen, die die spähen ja sogar die UN aus,
Und da sagt er, also ich gehe davon aus, dass amerikanische Stellen uns nicht ausspionieren. Ähm und dann sagt äh Thomas Oppermann, äh SPD, der sitzt in dem parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium der Geheimdienste, sagte
ich weiß gar nicht, wo sie in den letzten Wochen waren und sagt,
Die NSA hat ja selber gesagt, dass sie die weltweite Kommunikation überwachen. Das ist völlig unstrittig. Ja, also.
Und was das Einzige, was die NSA gesagt hat, ist die UL, die die Bundesrepublik überwachen wir nicht flächendeckend.
Es gibt vermutlich noch die Bereiche, die so schlecht mit DSL versorgt sind. Da kommen wir noch nicht ran.
Und es muss also eine völlig skurrile Sendung gewesen sein. Also es und dann.
Meinte der Oppermann dann nicht auch noch irgendwie so ja woher er denn das sie sitzen doch in dem sie sitzen doch in dem PKG, ne.
Friedrich verwies darauf, dass Oppermann, Vorsitzende des äh Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums ist, woraufhin man meinte, ja, deswegen weiß ich auch, wovon ich rede.
Aber du musst ja nicht im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium sitzen, um irgendwie Nachrichten lesen zu dürfen.
Na ja, vermutlich doch.
Also das ist wirklich ähm.
Das ist schon ein bisschen tragisch. Also man muss sich langsam auch wirklich Sorgen machen.
Das ist wirklich ein das ist wirklich ein tragischer Fall. Ähm insbesondere also er sagte dann auch,
gegen die Vorwürfe gäbe es keine Belege, obwohl man die in alle Richtungen gesucht hätte. Also was willst du dazu noch sagen? Ich meine, was für eine Form von Beleg meint er denn, wo zu finden?
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich, die sitzen da wahrscheinlich in diesem Raum, spielen blinde Kuh und der hat einfach den Topf äh,
beim Topfschlagen verloren. Das ist versteht das auch nicht. Ich meine, eigentlich ist es auch lächerlich und ich was ich eigentlich nicht verstehe ist, warum die Medien diesen Typen nicht einfach zerfetzen,
Also ich meine, gab's schon mal.
Nur ansatzweise so ein Gehhampel, also solche Hanebücher am Ende auch, was der da von sich äh äh gibt, das ja.
Ne, die Medien.
Also die Medien TM schreiben ja schon was die sagen und schreiben auch im gleichen Artikel was alles sich allein in dieser Woche ergeben hat, wo er dann das auch sehr schön hat, denn,
da muss es wohl auch, also wie gesagt, ich habe diese Sendung nicht gesehen. Ich habe keinen Fernseher, ich kann sowas nicht sehen, aber ich lese dann die Zusammenfassung. Wenn äh Cem Özdemir äh vor den Grünen sagte, ähm,
Ja, also wir, ne, als als Parlamentarier erfahren aus den aus der Zeitung mehr als ähm.
Von der Bundesregierung.
Von den Gremien und ich erwarte jetzt meine Überprüfung und da antwortet Friedrich mit zwei Worten.
Alles überprüft.
Das ist so.
Nee, das ist, also ist nicht mehr lustig. Das ist also dieser Mann ist ähm.
Vollständig überfordert von der Situation, in der er ist. Ich vermute nee, ich also ich.
Fünf fünf Sätze drin und die ruft er immer wieder ab.
Es gibt jetzt zwei Optionen. Also aus meiner Sicht so.
Wir haben in einem Monat Wahlen oder weniger, drei Wochen oder was, ne? Und danach können zwei Sachen passieren. Entweder der äh hohe Rat der CDU stellt fest,
hat geklappt? Kann's weitermachen? Oder der wird ähm.
Einfach in an, kriegt ein anderes Ministerium oder aus gesundheitlichen Erwägungen, mh goldenen Handschlag. Aber,
Also ich denke, auf dieser Kippe ist er gerade, ja. Es bringt jetzt auch nix mehr den, also.
Wird nicht Innenminister bleiben, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Weiß ich nicht. Also man würde hoffen, dass dieser Mensch am besten einfach gar nichts mehr wird. Egal was. Also.
Nee, ihr kriegt ein Haus, irgendwie ein Oberbayern. Mit Garten.
Jemanden, der ihm den Hintern abputzt und dann ist gut, weißt du? Also.
Betreuung, einfach hm.
Also einfach die normale Versorgung, also die, die normale Versorgung für so einen Wachkoma-Patienten, die steht dem auch zu, die will ich ihnen jetzt auch gar nicht verwehren, ja. Ähm das,
Das sollte man diesen Menschen jetzt auch zukommen lassen. Ne? Aber ähm.
Wachkoma,
Bundeswachkomma mindestens.
Nee, also ich weiß nicht, ab und zu gucken, ne, dass der sich nicht wundlicht oder so, aber ähm was muss man damit denn machen? So, aber der kann ja jetzt nicht ein Ministerium führen.
Es ist wirklich echt unglaublich.
Andererseits, ja, andererseits,
ähm Metronaut hatte jetzt bei Metronaut hatte Mikael in den Pfad vor ein paar Tagen veröffentlicht, irgendwie dreizehn Gründe, Schwarz-Gelb zu wählen, ja? Und wenn man sich diese Gründe mal so anschaut, ähm,
dann machte er Friedrich echt noch eine gute Figur.
Warum?
Ja, klick mal da an. Also, was haben wir jetzt? Dreizehn Gründe zusammengestellt. Also, Gutenberg, Shavan, Horst Köhler, Christian Wulff, Franz Josef Jung,
Norbert Röttgen, Dirk Niebel, ja, Thomas de Maizire, Hans-Peter Friedrich. Ja, oh, er hat ihn dazu, äh, er war, er hat ihn mit dazu genannt, ja. Äh, aber in dieser Reihe ist der Friedrich ja noch ein Moderat.
Rainer Brüderle, Wolfgang Schäuble, Finanzminister, ja, mit den hunderttausend Mark. Das war ja nur, das war ein schöner Moment, das äh äh.
Müssen wir eigentlich nochmal zurückgetreten, Herr.
Er hat für Röster Platz gehört.
Sexuelle Belästigung und es gibt da wohl ist ein Video verlinkt, wie er betrunken von einer Bühne fällt,
Das ist doch echt eine geile, illustre Runde, das wäre doch schade, die alle jetzt auf einen Schlag wegzuhaben. Aber übrigens, wie Hermann Gremlitzer schön in äh in der Konkret schrieb, ähm,
Im Prinzip, also wenn die FDP es nicht schaffen sollte und die Grünen sich ein letztes Mal zieren, nur dann gibt's überhaupt eine Aussicht auf Schwarz-Rot. Also mit anderen Worten so, also schwarz gelb ist so sicher wie das äh.
In der Kirche. Äh okay, wir wir schweifen ein bisschen ab. Also, Friedrich und Pofalla, man wird sehen,
Und ich würde mich nicht wundern, also entweder die müssen jetzt sang und klanglos irgendwo verschwinden,
Gelegenheit bietet sich gerade, die ohne Debatte halt aus dem Amt zu kriegen.
Also in drei Wochen.
In drei Wochen, ja, neues Kabinett vorstellen, sagen wir und klanglos einfach, nee, der hat jetzt, ich weiß nicht, Blumenzüchtung angefangen oder sagt, ähm aber.
Das ändert natürlich auch herzlich wenig. Also ich meine, das ist ja nun äh dass er, äh dass sie jetzt grade in meine das ist ja das, das Bedrückende an dieser ganzen Situation ist, dass es eben doch schon zeigt, wie,
Stark, der Einfluss der Geheimdienste jetzt innerhalb des politischen Systems ist, unabhängig davon, was sie tun,
Ja, aber es traut sich ja auch wirklich keiner ran an den Braten, ne? Im Prinzip wieder genau bei dem äh Einstiegsthema,
ne, so die äh Verwaltung ähm des Zustands, anstatt äh das äh Benennen politischer Ziele, weil äh ich kann mir jetzt nicht unbedingt vorstellen, dass sie jetzt sich so besonders wohl fühlen,
in dieser Situation da permanent äh wie soll ich das ausdrücken, ja? Äh nicht unbedingt den Gestaltungsspielraum zu haben, von dem sie immer meinen, ihn zu hätten oder von dem sie zumindest behaupten, ihn zu haben.
Und aber auch dagegen äh rührt sich eben auch kein Widerstand. Ob das jetzt aus Angst oder aus Unwissen oder Unfähigkeit äh heraus ähm tatsächlich passiert, ich weiß es nicht, aber was ist da,
äh fischi, ja.
Gut, aber dann sind halt so Vögel wie der Friedrich auch im Prinzip komplett austauschbar.
Ja, natürlich.
Lustig, wenn man mal so einen Hampelmann hat, auf den man sich dann irgendwie schön mal wieder ein paar Kalauer äh zusammenreiben kann. Eine war's.
Aber einer wird ja reichen. Ein Hampelmann.
Ist ja auch nur einer.
Ja, er ist jetzt einer, der hat ja noch einen Hampelmann daneben hängen, einen Pofalla. Na ja, also okay, hören wir.
Das ist für mich eher so ein Symptom, ja? Und das ist jetzt nicht das eigentliche Problem. Es ist natürlich schon äh also da tippt jetzt sein Name dran, aber das eigentliche Problem ist, dass quasi die gesamte äh politische Klasse einfach nach wie vor nicht wirklich Stellung beziehen.
Ja? Die sind wahrscheinlich auch grade Schock gefroren, weil sie einfach von der Wahl äh eigentlich gelernt haben, Füße stillhalten, äh äh nicht sagen, ist immer noch besser, als was falsches sagen. Und genau dieses Programm ziehen sie jetzt einfach eisern durch.
Und damit werden sie wahrscheinlich auch durchkommen. Ist halt so.
Die das ist genau das ist genau das, was ich meine, ne. Also eventuell es.
Es kann sein, dass der einfach mit der ganzen Nummer durchkommt, der Friedrich. Und dann einfach nochmal vier Jahre weitermacht und dass wir als Gesellschaft schon soweit sind, dass dass man sowas mit uns machen kann. So.
Kommen wir zu einem.
Thema.
Anderen schönen Thema.
Sie war schon öfter Thema, die ähm Netzneutalitätsverordnung, die das Bundes äh Wirtschaftsministerium ja jetzt da erarbeitet hat. Wir erinnern uns, sie sagen, ja, nee, also äh diskriminieren,
im Internet absolut nicht okay, aber natürlich dürft ihr managed Services anbieten,
Das also heißt, ihr könnt diskriminieren, natürlich, ne. Ähm der Managed Service, also ein als aus dem Internet heraus partialisiertes Internet, welches dann.
Ähm ja, bevorzugt.
Sonderbehandlung.
Eine Sonderbehandlung erfährt, ja. Und das heißt natürlich, in dem Moment, wo ich etwas,
besser behandle, als das,
geschieht es, zu Lasten von etwas anderem. Ja, und das ist ja die lange, das ist ja, ich ich wiederhole es jetzt nochmal kurz, wir äh verweisen ansonsten auf unsere Sondersendung zur zur Netznetralität. Ähm.
Das Problem entsteht in dem Moment, wo man das mit finanziellen äh Bedingungen verknüpft. Ja, also es hat keiner etwas dagegen, wenn die Deutsche Telekom.
Mir eine E-Mail langsamer zustellt, weil mein Nachbar gerade ein HD Video auf YouTube schaut.
Quality of Service, stellt erstmal keine Herausforderung.
Politische politische Forderung in Deutschland, ja? Kann man nur über zwei äh Vergleichsarten wirklich plastisch rüberbringen. Fußball,
und Autobahn, ja? Das ist das Einzige, was funktioniert. Hier sollen einfach zusätzliche Spuren auf der Autobahn gebaut werden, für die man extra zahlt,
und wenn da gefahren wird, dann äh muss der Rest halt langsamer fahren, anhalten, da ist dann halt Stau,
Ja, das ist halt Priorität, ne? Und wenn da halt einer lang will, dann ist auch egal, wenn da dann Stau entsteht, weil weil das ist ja managed. Ja, das ist ja ein Managed Service,
ähm das beeinflusst ja die offene Autobahn nicht. Die ist ja nach wie vor äh zugänglich, was wollt ihr eigentlich, ja
aber was diese diese großen Karossen müssen doch halt auch irgendwie vorwärts kommen, das ist halt total wichtig.
Mir fällt da dieses schöne äh Bild hierzu ein. Ich werde das dann mal im Artikel auch zeigen, aber du erinnerst dich an das hier, ne?
Ah ja genau die äh die Olympia, die hatten wir glaube ich schon in einem anderen äh.
Machen wir nochmal.
Beitrag gebracht. Äh genau. Das hatte ich jetzt gar nicht im Kopf, aber genau das ist es.
Es fand also jetzt ein ein Treffen im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium statt, da gab's dann hauptsächlich Kritik vom von der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband oder dem Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband, ich weiß immer nicht, wie die ob die welche ist, welche.
Bundesverband Verbraucherzentrale heißt es doch glaube ich.
Nee, VZW-Frau, Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband, keine Ahnung, die haben,
es ist Mist, was ihr euch da ausgedacht habt. Und der Verband der Zeitungsverleger auch. Und der Eco, ne, Frau Weiderverband, der dann sagte, ähm es gibt schon Klassen, nur eben nicht gegen Bezahlung,
und ähm.
Jemand, da wurde der Name nicht genannt, sagte man müsse sich jetzt endlich mal von der Lebenslüge verabschieden, dass bei einer Zweiklassenübertragung ähm
der die zweite Klasse nicht ausgebremst würde zugunsten der äh der Ersten, ja? Ähm also,
auch da glücklicherweise nicht nur von äh von Bürgerrechtlern äh und Verbraucherschützern etwas Gegenwind. Ähm,
Was jetzt passieren wird Anfang September macht das.
Also warte mal, das mit der Lebenslüge kam jetzt auch vom Eco oder was?
Nicht genannter Lobbyist. Es wahrscheinlich hat der äh Journalist, der da mitgesessen hat, sie einfach nicht gemerkt, wer das gesagt hat.
Also ihr meint, das ist so so ein bisschen wie im ICE, der ICE, der im ICE fährt die erste und die zweite Klasse ja auch gleich schnell oder was?
Nein.
Also was was das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium doch macht, ist zu sagen, wir wollen keine Diskriminierung.
Aber Diskriminierung ist trotzdem erlaubt.
Wir machen wir machen zwei Klassen und innerhalb dieser findet keine Diskriminierung statt. Ja, also zu sagen so, es gibt halt genau, es gibt.
Innerhalb. Genau. Also innerhalb der ersten Klasse kriegt jeder das gleiche Essen.
Die Weißen sitzen vorne im Bus, die schwarzen hinten und alle werden auf ihrer, in ihrem Teil des Busses gleichbehandelt.
Es gibt keine Diskriminierung. Das ist das, was die, was die, was das Bundesministerium macht. Wir, ja,
und sagen also innerhalb der Klassen gibt's keine Diskriminierung, also ist das diskriminierungsfrei. Es gibt zwar Klassen, aber die sind ja unterschiedliche Klassen, sorry, also ist ja keine Diskriminierung. So.
Das ist das, was wir machen. Und mit genau mit dieser Lebenslüge wird er gesagt, äh soll halt mal aufgeräumt werden, weil es halt zu,
Das ist halt wirklich Unsinn, zu sagen, wir trennen in zwei Klassen, innerhalb der Klassen gibt's keine Diskriminierung und äh deswegen äh ist das Ganze diskriminierungsfrei. Ja, totaler Unsinn,
Also, wie geht's mit der Sache weiter? Anfang September machen sie nochmal einen Workshop mit den Kommunikationsanbietern. Ich bin mal gespannt, was die dazu sagen.
Ähm und dann wollen sie mit dieser Verordnung vermutlich in ihr in die Koalitionsverhandlungen marschieren. Das Schlimme an dieser Netzneutralitätsverordnung ist eben, dass sie genau das Gegenteil ist, ja? Sie ist eine,
gegen Netzneutralitätsverordnung,
steht aber groß dran Netzneutralität und Gleichbehandlung. Das ist wirklich ähm enorme Augenwischerei, was da passiert.
Dann gab's noch.
Diskriminierung ist Netzneutralität.
Ja.
Ja. Dann gab's noch eine kleine Meldung, jetzt jetzt kommen wir noch so zu den Kurzmeldungen der Woche.
Aus der Abteilung. Wir haben nichts zu verbergen.
Aus der Time, wir haben nichts zu verbergen,
Wir erinnern uns an den an den Aufschrei der äh uns letztes Jahr glaube ich, ereilte als die Schuh vermeide, wir wollen mal bei Facebook gucken, da gibt's Daten und wir machen ja hier was mit Daten, vielleicht können wir da ein bisschen was raus daten. Ähm und zwar ging's hauptsächlich darum, dass also das,
dass dein Facebook-Profil,
was auch immer daran auffällig sein mag, äh mit in dein Kredit-Rating aufgenommen werden soll, ja? Und da gibt's also stellte sich jetzt raus, dass es solche Auskunft teilen gibt, die mit Sitz in den USA,
die genau das machen.
Wobei bei der Schufa war es ein Forschungs äh.
Schufa ging es um ein Forschungsprojekt. Ich hatte das ja damals auch ein bisschen äh ähm,
Bisschen so beleuchtet, dass ich sage, okay, die wollten halt mal rausfinden, ob sich daraus etwas vorhersagen lässt. Ja, wenn sich daraus etwas hätte vorher sagen lassen, dann hätten sie das natürlich auch einfließen lassen in ihren Algorithmus,
Es ist nie dazu gekommen, weil die kooperierende, das kooperierende Institut dann gesagt hat, also mit dem aufmerk öffentlichen Interesse und dieser äh Abwehrhaltung ähm
wollen wir da äh das Ganze lieber gar nicht erst machen. Ähm,
In USA stellt sich raus, gibt's also dann so Auskunft, teilen, die es längst machen, die so ein bisschen darauf achten, ähm,
Du hast Facebook-Freunde, du bist mit jemandem auf Facebook befreundet, der bei uns schon als säumiger Zahler bekannt ist, dann steckt er doch unter einer Decke. Ja, also solche Dinge. Gibt's also schon.
Das nur als äh also da kann man jetzt nur eine kleine Randmeldung draus machen,
Und dann, was ich sehr interessant fand, sind ähm.
Verkaufsprospekte von Gamma geliebt worden.
Die sind in einen, die sind irgendwie aufgetaucht. Ähm und da geht's also einmal um deren ähm GSM Überwachungs äh.
Methoden, wo sie also, ja, im Seecatcher und solche äh Sachen drin bewerben,
bis hin zu Massen äh also Wildband Sniffing, wo man also sagt, äh wir schneiden einfach einmal komplett GSM mit zum nachher entschlüsseln.
Ja, jetzt hast du gerade genau die andere die andere PDF aufgemacht. Ähm also das war jetzt mal, ich hab's das Ganze nicht mehr downloaden bei Box dot net.
Dot com. Ähm also tschuldigung,
wo sie also man sieht, sie sie zeigen dort ihr Ortungs und Abhörequipment im im Mobilfunknetzbereich. Das Ganze hat einen Stand von zweitausendelf, das heißt, es ist davon auszugehen, dass sich eventuell in der Zeit auch nochmal was getan hat,
Ähm das also ein interessing read, also was sie da so für so ne dein Fahrzeug ausbauten zum, also ein GSM Ortendes und abhörendes Auto können sie dir bauen. Ähm.
Die man am, also als Anzüge am Körper trägt. Und also aller sei äh allerlei sehr skurriles ähm Abhörequipment, was sie da so äh rumfliegen haben.
James Bond mäßig.
Ja, ähm das naja, ist das nur James Bond mäßig. Du hast immer noch das falsche Off, ne. Mach mal GSM auf.
Ich habe hier beide.
Ähm das ist nicht nur James Bond mäßig. Also diese Dinge kommen zum Einsatz und das ist das, was sie nutzen, um.
Nee, ich meine jetzt diese kleinen, die man jetzt irgendwie noch so äh überall eben mal so ansteckt noch immer so, dass das GSM-Netzwerk äh in der Gürteltasche das äh ne, könnte hätte Q jetzt auch mal.
Der interessante Teil äh der interessante Teil sind dann die Sections vier und fünf. Also sie haben in in drei sagen sie so, was sie jetzt so alles bauen an
GSM Sniffern. Also erstmal Geräte, die möglichst viele äh Frequenzen, die SM empfangen und irgendwie wegschreiben. Und ähm
da gibt's dann alles Mögliche. Von klein zu groß, von in Auto eingebaut zu äh irgendwie äh mehrere Höheneinheiten und äh endlos viele Antennen dran.
Und ähm verkaufen, also gezielte Maßintercept äh Wildbandlösung, also ein Gerät,
man hinstellt, was wirklich einfach mal so bis zu, also gibt's in mehreren Ausbaustufen, bis zu die gesamte GSM Kommunikation in der Umgebung,
erstmal einfach wegschreibt,
Und dann äh mit einem entsprechenden kann man dann auch jedes einzelne der jede einzelne der Transaktion, die da stattfindet, SMS-Telefonate,
entschlüsseln ähm und das Ganze sogar äh passiv, ja, also es geht,
nicht mehr man braucht für für diese für GSM Intercept nicht mehr einen aktiven Imseecatcher, sondern das kann man also vollkommen unbemerkt mit einer Antenne machen,
ähm.
Hm schon auch eindrücklich auf den Kongressen gezeigt wurde. Du hast ja auch mit Carsten Nohl da ein äh CAE zugemacht.
Mhm.
Disclaimer, ich arbeite für Carsten Nohl. Ähm diese, also diese Sachen bieten sie da jetzt zum Verkauf an und ähm,
das finde ich schon relativ krass, weil der Anwendungsfall für einen Masseninterzept GSM ist dann auch, denke ich, nicht mehr durch ähm.
Durch ja Strafverfolgung zu rechtfertigen, ja? Also gezielte im kann man immerhin noch argumentieren, dass man es damit auf eine spezifische Person absieht und die könnte ja auch ein Terrorist sein
und wat nicht alles, ja? Also da da gibt es wenigstens noch ein Argumentationslinie, die zwar auch nicht unbedingt.
Besonders bückerechts schonend ist, aber da gibt es eine,
Ähm bei Massen abhören von GSM Kommunikation gibt's die beim besten Willen nicht mehr.
Es zeigt auch mal, also das ist wirklich mal sehr interessant, mal dieses ganze Portfolio auch so in einem.
Fünfzig Seiten.
Ja, so nach dem Motto so, hier stay of the Art, Abhörtechniken, zack. So, es geht einfach alles.
Und auch also sagen, zeigen auch auf die nächste Generation. Ähm,
wo es also dann darum geht, dass die aktuellen Schwächen in den GSM-Netzwerken werden jetzt grade so in Europa nach und nach durch Softwareupdates abgebaut,
und äh Gama, das war das, was mich daran äh wirklich überrascht hat, wirbt in diesem Material von zweitausendelf schon für Produkte, die trotz verschiedener randomization Maßnahmen immer noch ein äh,
vollkommene Entschlüssung von GSM Versprechen. Was äh schwierig ist. Also es wird relativ teuer sein. Ähm.
Hat mich überrascht, dass die zweitausendelf schon soweit waren,
quasi, dass die fix ist, die jetzt grade bei den Netzwerken in den letzten sagen wir mal hier in dem letzten Jahr langsam ausgerollt werden in Europa, dass sie denen auch schon wieder voraus sind. Das äh.
Ähm war für mich so nicht klar. Ähm was sie auch noch haben, ist äh sehr spannend, wenn du nochmal kurz zu dem Inhaltsverzeichnis gehen könntest, das GSM-Material. Ähm und zwar.
Gehen sie über das SS sieben, also über das Netz quasi, was, wodurch die,
Telkos sich untereinander verbinden,
dass äh also es ist Protokoll, was die untereinander sprechen, heißt halt äh Signaling System seven. Da gibt's auch schon Vorträge für, auch schon fünf, sechs Jahre alt, wie man darüber,
Abfragen machen kann, welch wo ein Nutzer sich momentan befindet, ja? Gibt's auch Online-Dienste für wo man eine Telefonnummer angibt,
und der Online-Dienst sagt einem, dieses Mobiltelefon befindet sich gerade äh ungefähr an dieser Stelle, weil es gerade in diesem Moment an dieser GSM-Zelle auf der Welt eingeloggt ist,
Ähm auch das äh wird da also ähm verkauft.
Was krass ist, weil sie damit wirklich in das also ich mein, wie gesagt, sind nicht nicht großartig überraschend, falls die die
Die Erkenntnisse, dass diese Sachen gehen schon seit seit Jahren öffentlich sind, aber in das Ausmaß, in dem diese Angriffe dann wirklich industrialisiert wurden und jetzt da äh verkauft werden, ähm ist dann schon
sehr ähm sehr überraschend, ja, also weltweite Ortung von Mobiltelefonen mithilfe von,
Provider Infrastrukturen, ohne dass die Provider das merken,
das schon ähm ja, wie gesagt, für jemanden, der sich länger, der sich schon länger damit auseinandersetzt, ist das jetzt alles,
Nicht so überraschend, dass diese Sachen gehen, also was was die machen, dass das geht, wusste ich dass sie das aber auch wirklich,
vollständig industrialisiert haben als fertige Produkte verkaufen. Ähm ist schon äh.
Starkes Stück.
Stück, aber ja gut, kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass das jetzt überraschend ist, dass dass die Leute so was verkaufen.
Ja, was mal äh wem bisher, sagen wir mal, die Dimension dieses dieser Industrialisierung der äh Überwachung äh nicht klar war, hier hat man das sozusagen in einem PDF mal schön äh zusammengefasst, äh auch wenn's teilweise mit
allerlei äh kryptischen Begriffen et cetera und Technologien versehen ist, aber zeigt schon mal sehr schön.
Also wer dieses dieses Material von Gamada, wir haben's verlinkt,
auf jeden Fall mal interessant, vor allem für Leute so als Einstieg. Falls ihr echt da noch so die Hintergrund äh erklären, ja, von was sind die Herausforderungen beim
GSM Verschlüsse, welche Maßnahmen werden gegen Maßnahmen, werden ergriffen und was kann man da wieder gegen tun? Und äh interessanterweise zeigen sie dann auch ähm,
Also bei drei G schaffen sie diesen nicht. Was sie dann dadurch lösen, dass sie das drei G Netz stören, um das Telefon ins 2G-Netz zu zwingen und dann abzuhören. Solche Sachen, also schon ein interessanter Überblick über den Stand der Technik äh dar,
Für Leute, die das interessiert auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessanter Einstieg, ebenso wie äh Karstens. Ähm Carsten CRE mit dir,
und dann natürlich auch ähm der äh Produktumfang zu Finn Fischer,
wo sie dann auch nochmal, also auch da nicht wirklich was Neues drin.
Also die Trojaner-Software von Garmaia, ne? Die sind gerne im Nahen Osten, aber auch in anderen Orten eingesetzt wird, um dann mal so.
Wie wir wissen, Deutschland jetzt grade äh testet,
Deutschland hat ja eine Testlizenz von äh Finn Fischer für hundert äh fünfzigtausend oder sowas gekauft von Gamma,
Ähm und na ja, die testen ja jetzt, wie sie das Ding irgendwie so runterdampfen können, dass es irgendwie an den deutschen an der deutschen Verfassung und Gesetzgebung äh vorbeigeschleust kriegen und dann zum Einsatz bringen können.
Tja, aber es ist äh immerhin kann dann äh unser Innenminister behaupten, dass wir alles überprüft.
Ja, da genau, das ist alles überprüft und was, was man da also sieht, ist, wir hatten vor langer Zeit schon mal eine Folge, wo wir uns über ähm Handel unterhalten haben, also was, ne, was mit dem Wissen über,
über Sicherheitslücken,
passiert ob. Das ist also für viele finanziell der größte Anreiz ist dieses Wissen zu nicht zu publizieren und stattdessen,
zu versilbern. Und wir sehen also, dass was das Gamma da offensichtlich,
eine der treibenden Kräfte hinter diesem Markt sein muss, ja? Weil diese ganzen,
Angriffsvektoren, die sie sich da zusammengestellt haben, nur für das äh Trojanisieren von Rechnern, ja. Also sei es irgendwie Angriffe über Firewire, über USB,
Ähm übers Netzwerk selber, beim ISP mit einer Kiste, die da im Regal steht und äh man in the middle, dein, dein Internet Traffic irgendwie
infiziert, sodass du dann den Trojaner auf deinem Computer hast. Trojaner für alle drei üblichen äh Betriebssysteme ähm,
für ähm Mobiltelefone mit Weboberfläche und und was sie nicht alles dabei haben, da sieht man also wo wo dieser, wo dieser Markt dann irgendwo am Ende,
akkumuliert, nämlich da bei denen. Also auch noch mal für den.
Und das ist ja jetzt, also genau das ist das Spannende, was was eigentlich das Fazit ist. Das verkaufen die ja an ähm Polizei,
Also das, was was äh was Gamma macht, verkaufen sie an Strafverfolgungsbehörden. Da musste also irgendwie muss eine Regierung sein, Strafverfolgungsbehörde, aber das ist jetzt nicht,
unbedingt für Geheimdienste. Das heißt, das ist also das, womit sie auch eine Polizei ausstatten,
Und das lässt dann tief blicken, wofür halt irgendwie einundzwanzig Prozent des,
USA, Intelligence Budgets in Krypto draufgehen, wenn das schon einfach der private Markt ist, der der so etwas hergibt. Die Privatwirtschaft.
Man staunt, man staunt.
Linos. Ja. Ich glaube, wir haben's, oder?
Ja, du siehst, ich ich sogar? Ja, du siehst, um mit diesen ganzen äh.
Macht dich ganz kirre.
Nur ich habe jetzt äh also diese Gamma-Sachen, da habe ich mich jetzt äh mehrere Tage so ein bisschen mit auseinandergesetzt, was da so alles drin steht und wie die so wie die so abgehen und das ist auch nochmal.
Lässt's auch anders zur zur Sorge.
So, was steht an?
Ja morgen verliert Union zu Hause.
Und darüber hinaus gibt's gerade irgendwas, mir fällt gerade kein Termin oder sonst.
Nächste Woche, nächste Woche, ach so, Termine. Ach, weiß ich nicht, ich bin nächste Woche nicht da.
Äh genau, das heißt, da werden wir vermutlich äh eine kleine Pause machen müssen.
Ich fliege nächste Woche ins feines Land.
Oha. Ja. Und dann.
Ist auch bald IFA.
Nächste Woche ist was, also am, nee, genau, da ich ja nächste Woche nicht da bin, muss ja darauf hingewiesen werden, dass dann am Wochenende oder am Samstag, den siebten September.
Die Freiheit statt Angstdemo stattfindet.
Statt Angstdemo stattfindet und gleichzeitig auch äh die Datenspuren und noch eine Veranstaltung im da habe ich jetzt gerade den Titel vergessen.
Die Datenspuren sind dann oh.
Ja, also sie stehen zumindest da in meinem Kalender. Es kann sein, dass.
Ähm da haben sich ja einen tollen Termin gelegt.
Naja, das kam daher, dass die Datenspuren ihren Termin gelegt haben und es jetzt so ein bisschen.
Es gab etwas wenig Absprachen über die Festlegung des Termines für die Freiheit statt Angstdemo. Sagen wir es mal so.
Weil ähm es wurde auch in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung dann mal nach der Freiheit statt Angst gefragt und dass die Freiheit Angst wird ja eigentlich von einem großen,
Bündnis ausgerichtet, wo dann immer alle
alle in Anführungszeichen dabei sind, ja? Und in diesem Jahr gab es dann ob der,
ob eines Alleingangs bei der Terminfestlegung durch ein bestimmte Person oder Gruppe da etwas Unstimmigkeiten,
was natürlich aus insbesondere sehr bedauerlich ist, wenn man sich überlegt, in welcher Situation wir heute sind und eine Freiheit statt Angstdemo äh für uns heute äh wichtiger ist, denn je.
Ähm ist das natürlich schade und bin ich natürlich auch ein äh Gegner davon, solche,
Konflikte ähm jetzt so etwas überschatten zu lassen. Deswegen will ich hier jetzt auch gar nicht größer machen als sie sind. Die ähm,
Demo wird stattfinden. Alle rufen dazu auf, das Demobündnis ist breit äh und man sollte dort hingehen, ja? Wenn man nicht gerade,
woanders ist.
Genau, wenn man nicht gerade in äh Dresden ist. Programm ist, glaube ich, noch nicht so ganz vollständig hier äh von Datenspuren. Ich hoffe, dass füllt sich noch. Ähm beständig. Schauen wir mal. Gut. Nina ist für mich.
Wir müssen noch so irgendwie noch ein bisschen, bisschen eindrehen. Ich habe für die Freiheit statt Angst werben. Wie machen wir das denn?
Weiß ich nicht, hingehen. Du bist nicht da. Das ist so.
Geht ihr nicht, bin ich da.
Ich gehe auch ich bin auch echt nicht da, also ihr.
Wir brauchen Tausende um um dein fehlendes Gewicht auszugleichen.
Ja, der geht da bitte hin und ähm.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also es ist in der Tat, also was da bemängelt wurde, dass die dass diese Mobilisierungswelle für die Freiheit statt Angstdemo ist tatsächlich, bleibt jetzt hinter meinen Erwartungen zurück? Muss ich auch sagen.
Ähm es gibt da äh.
Für mich keinen erkenntlichen Grund für, warum das so ist. Oder auf jeden Fall keinen, den ich akzeptieren würde als Grund. Und ähm ich man kann nur hoffen, dass diese Demo also wirklich.
Von vielen, vielen, vielen zigtausend Menschen besucht wird und da eine riesige äh riesige Deo stattfindet, um da mal ein Zeichen zu setzen.
Wo hier überhaupt die.
Dann Punkt auf diese Karte zu bekommen, ne, Proteste, ne.
Ein weiteres Aufblitzen, da ist die Frage, ob da Demonstrationen auch schon darunter gehört, ne. Glaube nicht.
Los Linus, Schluss jetzt hier, das war's. Äh Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wir sehen uns nicht ganz in der Woche, aber bald dadrauf.
So sieht's aus. Ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.